thank you all for coming and thank you
Ethan for that blurb if you'd like to
follow along you can go to regal dialog
slash talk the slides roll in line and I
really appreciate that blurb and
actually the book is now available in
Amazon I think you can buy it and
there's already been a review and I'm
fascinated by one-line reviews and I
thought this one was quite interesting
oh that's not working oh here we go
in that this is the first review in the
book regal knows a subject and sprinkles
enough curse words throughout his book
to make it NSFW if you were going to
read it aloud I'm not going to be
reading it but I'm gonna be talking
about it and the reason this chagrin it
amuses me is well hopefully that's not
the greatest contribution this book to
have has is that I have a lot of curse
words in it but this book very much was
inspired by WTF moments right what the
frak as they say on Battlestar Galactica
or I might say white what the heck and
of all the moments that really inspired
this book I want to show you a clip of a
video that really made me think what the
heck is going on here
didn't say I'm ugly
so tell me hey my so seeing teens going
on YouTube one of the places where the
commenting culture is understood as
being the worst asking YouTube
commenters am i ugly this just blew my
mind and I was like what the heck is
going on and again this book I had a lot
of experiences and moments like that
which then inspired me to say I want to
try to figure out if I can understand
what's going on and when I saw this I
used to work with Tim berners-lee the
guy that invented the web I worked at
the World Wide Web Consortium and I
don't think that was Tim's intention or
our intention that this was what the web
is gonna be but when I began thinking
about it a little bit more historically
I ended up surprising myself because if
I thought back in time I've been on the
web since 93 94 since it was first
created
but when friends and family started
talking about the web back and say mm
this is what they were talking about
this site hot or not this is how the web
came to the popular attention for a lot
of people who weren't like computer
science students like myself and this
was a site where you could upload a
picture of yourself and people could
click am i high or am I not and so it
seems actually the web's really good at
this sort of stuff as our social
networks P perhaps people know that
Facebook actually began as a site called
Facemash Zuckerberg was a student at
Harvard Harvard have had dormitories and
houses where students live and they had
directories there with students names
and pictures called Facebook's and so he
went online he wrote a scraper he
Kurland
the photos of Harvard students pulled
them into a website application called
Facemash so him in his fellow mail geeks
could click on one of the women were hot
or not right and so it seems both the
web and a lot of the social media
platforms out there are really well
suited to this sort of thing and in fact
one of YouTube's founders said he
created YouTube in part via inspiration
of hot or not Joe Wade Corinne said this
was the site where it first occurred to
him that people would be able to upload
content it was user-generated content
but it was more than that people were
just uploading pictures of themselves it
was that other people were able to rate
and comment on the content that other
people were uploading so it had the user
drain it generated content and the users
comment upon it and so I think to
understand the web as it exists today we
really do need to understand comment but
that raises the question of what is
comment so it's reactive I don't know if
that'll mute
that'll mute the visual yeah that's it
that's all that's all this sound so so
when YouTube extended the period of
video clips you could post on YouTube a
couple of years ago they said you can
have 10 hour long video clips and I
don't know how many people have made use
of 10 hour video clips but things that
do exist up there are these sound loop
clips and actually I wrote a lot of this
book listening the Darth Vader breathing
I found it kind of soothing and under
you know under that YouTube video you
find someone leaving the comet what am I
doing with my life 10 hours of breathing
so comments are reactive they're in
response to something though they're not
always responsive right we know that
expression TLT are too long didn't read
so they are reactive but not necessarily
substantively responsive they're also
short I include Plus Ones and likes as
within the purview of comment maybe a
couple paragraphs perhaps a couple of
sentences no more than a paragraph or
two they're asynchronous so you might
get a response back from someone
immediately or an hour or in a day but
you might quibble with any of those sort
of definitions there's 140 characters as
a 12 words and I will admit that my
criteria my attributes are a little bit
loosey-goosey but the essence of what
I'm talking about is best captured in a
number of tweets from
a developer shameless GaN who had this
wonderful Twitter account called avoid
comments and he had about a hundred
tweets on there just talking about
comments are so horrible your best
avoiding them
and he wrote there's a reason that
comments are at the bottom of the
internet I say web for a particular
reason that I won't get into you know
it's they're terrible and they deserve
to be at the bottom so when I started
this book I was like well what could we
learn given all these WTF moments in
sifting through the comments and I think
we can learn things about ourselves and
about how others seek to exploit our
social selves and so I've read the
comments so you don't have to write I
took an expedition to the bottom of the
web I explored various places I visited
various communities including Amazon
reviewers mean kids different commenting
communities that live under other
people's posts including free thinkers
scammers fakers makers takers lots of
different sort of places I went to and
so our mission for today is to consider
four different questions I call them the
mysteries of comment why do people
abandon comment platforms why are
comments often so awful can we trust the
comments at the bottom of the web and a
reprise of WTF so let's talk about the
migration the boom and the bust one of
the questions I'd like to ask my
students is we've had lots of different
messaging and platform content is it
over and I want to engage this topic by
way of a story about Trent Reznor is
anyone ever heard of Trent Reznor maybe
half not everyone right but he's the
frontman of a band I like Nine Inch
Nails that's known for a very sort of
Angry industrial kind of sound and he
stumbled upon Twitter in about 2009 and
he was tickled pink to characterize him
in a weird way because he can see he's
kind of angry looking here and he said I
went on Twitter and I realized I was
able to express myself a little more
authentically I was able to let down the
curtain but he didn't stay for long he
said I'm leaving because it
it's rule and so what prompted him to so
quickly engage and then leave Twitter
and I think his example is demas certain
for a lot of people and not only have
people abandon various messaging
platforms but platforms themselves and
websites have experimented with turning
comments off or trying to fix comments
and so I've noticed various migrations
we started out in geo cities we had
mayest base we have Facebook Twitter
Google+ Instagram snapchat amongst
people who like to comment on geek news
sites I started out on slash dot then I
followed a dig and I still follow a
little bit of Reddit and I pry spend
more of my time on Hacker News so again
why are we sort of always migrating like
a massive bison so I think this is part
of the reason why edits start Twitter
felt edgy and intimate I knew a lot of
people when Twitter came on lying that
were quite pleased because they had a
chance encounter with a celebrity
someone retweeted them or someone spoke
to them on Twitter and they were just
you know really pleased with the idea
similarly celebrities famous people this
was a space where they could actually
lower the cart curtain as Trent Reznor
said and so a lot of people were getting
something out of this experience when it
was relatively small and in fact it's
not surprising people like talking about
themselves communication theorists know
that when we are shooting sort of the
informally we spend 30 to 40
percent of our time on gossip and
researchers have found that this is
still the case on Twitter today and in
fact for a long time gossip was kind of
looked down upon among people who
studied communications and actually a
evolutionary theorist ended up changing
that in that Robin Dunbar had asked this
question of himself why is it that
primates and humans in particular have
such big brains and he ended up arguing
it's gossip that actually is the most
important thing and the reason he made
that argument is he looked at lots of
variables and tried to figure eight
figure out what correlates with brain
size and an animal's environment it
wasn't what they ate it wasn't how they
look moved around it actually correlated
with how much
they spent in groups group size the one
measure of social complexity available
to me at the time did correlate with
neocortex size
so among monkeys for instance and chimps
they spend time picking the fleas off of
one another's backs right and we know
that they use this to form alliances and
if one monkey is attacked by another
monkey a friend is likely to come in and
defend that monkey based on how recently
they groomed one another and Dunbar
argued humans do the same sort of thing
but we've grown up growing outside the
bounds of picking fleas off of one
another's backs instead we talk about
one another we gossip about one another
and one of the key insights here for
comments are that there's a certain
scale to the to the number of people
whose fleas you can pick off of
similarly there's a scale to the number
of people you can kind of gossip about
and Dunmore put that number at 150
people those are the people that you
know fairly well such that not only do I
know my friends but I know the friends
of my friends and if the friend of my
friend is my enemy you're my enemy of my
friend is my friend so 150 people is
that what he calls a clan it's that
small group of people that you have some
sense of what their secondary
relationships are like and at some point
though one Facebook probably have more
friends than 150 people but at some
point we will reach that stage in online
commenting platforms where you go beyond
that scale where you start asking who
brought that guy and you start getting
hit by spam and scammers and you realize
this place isn't funny isn't fun anymore
and I think that's what's happened on
Twitter and so many other sort of places
and what I call this is intimate
serendipity I think we're looking for a
way to express an authentic sense of
ourselves because we like to gossip we
like to self-disclose
without feeling that we're getting
harassed or stalked or getting undue
scrutiny while remaining open to things
that will surprise and delight us when I
go on Facebook for instance I don't find
very much of interest there maybe that's
my friend's fault but most of it is what
you would expect kind of various memes
and tropes and advertisements that don't
really sort of care for and what has
happened is when you're on a platform
that intimate serendipity turns to what
resinar called sludge when he went on
Twitter he already had a forum on his
website Nine Inch Nails calm and
incompetence Ann's who would basically
harass him and hate on him all the time
and Twitter was a breath of fresh air
for him because they had not yet found
him and the thing that chased him off
Twitter is the metal contingency had
succeeded and I love the quote treasurer
because he's so mean it depresses me to
think my art and life's work and attract
this kind of scum you trolling cowardly
pigs you succeeded and that was his
flounce
he left but lots of people have disabled
comments or stepped away from comments
in a less sort of vicious way perhaps
booing bullying has long struggled with
comments for a little while they
experimented with disemboweling when I
first saw this I was quite tickled they
basically if you post a comment that
they think is inappropriate they would
remove all the vowels from your words
and the idea was that what that would
make you upset or angry and school you a
little bit it only lasted for a year and
research actually seems to indicate that
schooling people and downloading people
for inappropriate behavior actually
often prompts them to act out even worse
and it's contagious within the community
because then people act even jerky and
then other people act turkey and it's
not necessarily a good thing but other
sites like Washington Post and gadget
and popular science have all turned
their comments off for periods were
forever and I think this is most ironic
because dave winer can be said to be one
of the foundational people in the
blogging space and he is at least of one
of two people who can be said to be the
first person to have enabled comments on
his blog yet now I'll take this for
granted but there was a time when this
was a new sort of thing and he has a bit
of a contentious personality he gets in
controversies but eventually he just
said I'm turning off the comments and so
I find this very telling that the person
who first had comments on his blog ended
up turning it off altogether
and so this is basically how I conceived
of that migration we're all looking for
intimate serendipity we're confronted by
the metal sludge and ads which I'm going
to come back to in a little bit and the
sites will try to create filters and
fortifications and moderation and meta
moderation and all these sort of schemes
to deal with the sludge and the spam and
ads but eventually people will migrate
and look and search for something else
so I now think about this Twitter there
was just news in the past week or two
that Twitter still hasn't managed to
make a profit and everyone's wondering
when that other shoe is gonna drop are
they gonna start putting ads and
people's Twitter streams are they gonna
start shaping which is alleged
supposably what you see because right
now you see everything that your friends
post whereas in facebook they shape what
you see twitter might start shaping what
you see and taking money from other
people to shape what you see it's gonna
have to happen eventually they're gonna
have to make a profit if they want to
succeed and then lots of people will
probably move on so let's turn to this
question of why where does the metal
sludge come from why are people just so
awful online and I want to introduce
this topic by way of a story of Kathy
Sierra Kathy Sierra is author she wrote
a really a number of good books about
Java she under the Reilly publisher
she's a popular blogger she had a very
uh well read widely read blog and she's
a speaker she would talk at lots of
different conferences she also did two
things that made her a target to
alienation one the second one is just
that she's just a woman it's not like
she did anything there but that brought
an undue amount of alienation and hate
upon her and a long time ago before we
knew better she actually said bloggers
should be able to delete inappropriate
comments from their site that's all she
did but a lot of horrible things
happened and in 2007 she posted
something on her blog saying I'm
scheduled to speak at a conference but
I'm at home the doors lock and I'm
terrified and she said as a public
person that lives online like any way
she's
see her shares snarky comments and
people being mean but it had reached a
new sort of level and she basically
disappeared for the from the web for at
least five years and why why does this
sort of stuff happen I want to keep it
simple because people have been studying
this for almost two or three decades now
when I talk about sort of the
theoretical background I think there's
two sets of theories that explain why
people are awful online the first is
good people acting badly and the second
which say bit more - is that bad people
acting out so if we look at that Kathy
Sierra case at the good people acting
badly what had prompted the harassment
of Kathy Sierra was a blog by the new
him a blog by the name of mean kids it
was set up by Christopher Locke and a
couple of his colleagues and you can't
read the subtitle here but it says this
is a book he's published the bombast
transcripts ransom screeds of rage boy
so his online pseudonym was rage boy and
he liked to take people down and he
wasn't harassing them he wasn't hating
on them but for instance he had called
Kathy Sierra a hopeless and you
could say well is that appropriate
inappropriate wasn't hateful wasn't
illegal but you had people out there
perhaps who were actually decent people
if you met them face to face but saying
things like this online and in this
really weird surreal turn of events
Christopher Locke did meet Kathy Sierra
face to face in a live segment one CNN
to try to work out their differences
which as I think was absurd and obscene
but some of the social theories apply to
all of this i classify into two groups
we have the media theories and so
starting in the 90s people began looking
at issues of what is it about online
computer mediated communications the pop
pop this sort of behavior and there are
a number of theories that I won't get
into too much right now and then we also
had various behavioral theories and so
some of the ideas are that when we're
online we lose some of our inhibition
we lose some of our norms or we don't
lose our norms altogether but we look to
a more salient group of people or a
community to say this is what's
appropriate for me to do or what not to
do and then there's theories of moral
disengagement I'll say a little bit more
about that later and so I'm not gonna
dig into it this isn't a literature
review but those are some of the social
theories that people have offered but
there's also more popular theories which
I think are really fun this is a comic
from when my favorite online comics geek
and poke that's available under Creative
Commons license so I could use them in
the book I was happy about but this says
the history of social in 1985 being a
troll was not as much fun someone that
bag on head yelling at someone
else we also had Gollum right the whole
story of the Lord of the Rings is you
have this powerful ring that renders you
invisible and gives you other sort of
powers and even the modest and virtuous
hobbits they were the only people that
got hold on to it for a little bit a
while but eventually even they would be
corrupted Gollum was corrupted and even
Frodo was corrupted in the end if you
remember he's in the volcano
Gollum Frodo doesn't want to give up the
ring Gollum bites it off and he falls
into the lava and that's how that ring
is destroyed but Frodo had actually
become corrupted too and we could even
go further back than that the story that
plates hotels in the Republic about guy
Gees started out as an honest Shepherd
found a ring of invisibility used its
power to kill the king bed his wife and
take over the kingdom not a very kind
statement on where King guy geez came
from but again it speaks to this
question of can we be virtuous in the
online context when we lack
accountability most popularly and most
recently this is sometimes referred to
as the internet theory which is
if you take a normal person you add
anonymity and an audience they will act
awfully so that's the take on why people
do awful things if we assume that
they're relatively normal people that
would probably treat you decently if you
met them face to face but there's
another set of people that I think are
worth considering - and that's bad
people acting out to the extent and it's
not a clear line that we can say some
people are bad
disordered or scary they too are online
so the harassment against Kathy Sierra
really sort of took up a lot of speed
when this guy we've got involved and for
a while I long wondered is we've a troll
or is he hater
a hater and I maintain a distinction I
say a troll his intention is to cause
trouble and they might say hateful
things but maybe they're being insincere
I think a hater is someone who's really
trying to demean and diminish and hurt
someone and so he got involved and he
said Kathy's protests about feeling
scared or just you know absurd she
thought she could take on the trolls she
fought the law laugh out loud culture
and the lull one and he was in prison
for a hacking charge which I won't get
into but when he came out with a new
swastika prison tattoo I'm like okay
he's moving from the troll to the hater
category in my mind at least he also
does something awful but fairly clever
on Twitter this week did anyone see that
just one or two people on Twitter now
you can you can tweet and pay Twitter to
make sure it reaches certain
demographics and have really good
demographic data and so he posted a
message that for a couple of pennies he
could post out his white supremacist
tweets to prominent african-american
twitter holders or to put a tweet out
sexist things to feminists and stuff
like that so that's still kind of trolli
but I actually do think he's quite the
hater now and there was actually a
recent study that was really quite
interesting that looked at personality
attributes and commenters online just in
2014 and they it was based on a survey
and they wanted to look at things like
narcissism and sadism and a couple of
other dark tetrad personality attributes
and see if there was any correlation
between people's posting frequency and
it turns out that there is a bit of a
correlation between people who post a
lot people who troll and these
personality characteristics and at the
most pathological level we had the
example of Luka Luka Magnotta which is
one of those
whenever I read about this because I
knew I wanted to mention it in the book
at least I would need what's called a
unicorn chaser does anyone know what a
unicorn chaser is yes some handy
actually this entire actually this an
entire system goes over to cute animals
but the unicorn chaser is the image to
chase the image from your head that
you've just seen that is so horrible
that you need to do some brain scrapping
after the fact right so as I was working
on this book I had my you know supply of
unicorn chasers and I have a really cute
dog too that helps but this person had
been posting videos on YouTube for a
number of years torturing and killing
kittens and eventually he killed his
lover and posted it online and ate the
body and he was found out fled Canada
people didn't know where he was going
this whole time he was commenting online
he had lots of pseudonyms teasing people
thanking his fans and eventually he was
found by the police in a German internet
cafe reading and posting comments about
himself so hopefully none of us will
encounter people like this but it's very
now very easy to do so online and even
if you have one you know psycho out of a
hundred online they can really have a
disproportionate effect so I think it's
these two things it's normal sort of
everyday people acting out badly and
some very scary people having a
disproportionate effect that explains in
part why we see such awfulness online
but the really important thing in the
Sierra case in a lot of cases since that
is that this notion of troll is
sometimes not as useful as it might be
when trolls started out before the
before the web on the internet and
Usenet and flame wars happen they were
fairly innocuous I mean people might be
really mean but they weren't trying to
ruin your life to chase you out of your
home which is what happens now and one
of the things about the Sierra case that
struck me was that when she was talking
about out about the harassment she was
receiving people were like well don't
confuse me with the haters for instance
Chris Locke might say yeah I called you
a hopeless but I never said I
hope you die
and I thought that was unfair to Sierra
because she's in the middle of what I
call a troll Plex right this is this
vortex of awfulness some people notable
people are saying not nice things under
there no names they also have the trolls
kind of weighing in on what's happening
you have the haters who really do want
to hurt her and punish her and then you
have everyone else sort of kibitzing and
weighing in and the issue of free speech
is coming up and it's like has nothing
to do with Congress in the First
Amendment this was just us asking
questions of is this what we want for
our community and is this be condoned or
condemned so I don't think the response
to say don't feed the trolls as
appropriate anymore I think the trolls
of the 1990s still sort of exist but we
now really do have a culture of lulz
lolz where you have this whole mix and
vortex of awfulness coming from all
kinds of quarters but now I want to
return back to that question of the ads
and that cycle I to put up there a
couple of minutes ago and I want to ask
that question of can we trust the
comments a simple answer no so there's
lots of reasons why we have corporate
astroturf Fein Samsung is most famous
for this you'll find lots of people
getting caught up and acting as a sock
puppet right I put a puppet on my hand
and it says I agree with Joseph he's
really smart
a lot of people do that personally there
might be CEOs of companies or executives
that accompanies or employees of
companies or a government official but I
think Samsung had actually done this as
a corporate PR policy so this is not all
that uncommon we also have state
propaganda there was a US Air Force call
for proposals where they said we were
looking for software to help us manage
multiple personas sock puppets so they
could go on a foreign website and do
propaganda and one person because
lead-time comments in favor of the
united states hopefully in the u.s. most
of this stuff is happening outside of
our borders though you never really
quite know at least officially
China and Russia are well known as
having thousands if not tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people that maintain the censorship
institutions and and leave fake comments
and support of Putin or whoever it might
be the people in Thailand who comment in
favor of the monarchy are actually a
uniformed unit of the military and we
didn't see much news of this but in
South Korea during their 2012 elections
there was a big crisis in controversy
associated with people manipulating
tweets and during that election that's
just the name of the Chinese a group of
people who do this sort of thing the
idea was you've got one rather than be
for posting a comment off the equivalent
of 50 Cent's so it's the whole idea of
having paid government pick colleges
similarly if you go back to that
commercial space and you're thinking oh
I'm reading a review of a product should
I buy it online if you look at the
research people are estimating about 10
to 30% of the commercial reviews on Yelp
or Amazon or whatever it might be are
fake and people research has been very
clever about how they went about this
estimate which I can talk about more if
people are interested but it's really
not that hard to find so for instance if
you go on Craigslist the title which is
cut off here says looking for people to
write Amazon reviews pay is $1.00 per
review but each review takes less than
one minute you could go into Craigslist
right now type review in at the search
box and you would find ads like this I
give props to Amazon because they've
taken a lot of these pressures and
brought it within their sort of system
and so on Amazon there's something known
as vine reviews is anyone a vine
reviewer I'm curious it's something like
if you were in the top 500 reviewers on
Amazon they will start sending you free
products and there was an obligation
that you review 75 80 it's changed over
time percent of the products you receive
and I think that's a good thing because
actually when I ask people do you know
what a vine review is they don't and it
means they got it for free but at least
if you do know
you are as the FTC in the United States
requires at least disclosing the fact
that this was a freebie or a subsidized
product that you got to review but you
still end up with weirdnesses like this
person reviewing a book called system
identification a frequency domain
approach and the review says if you're
into math you'll love this book that's
it so this is one of the sources of sort
of the worst reviews on Amazon I'm
actually hoping to have my book get vine
reviews on Amazon I think we we've
started the process cuz I'm really
curious what will happen and the
response to a lot of this is if we say
we really can't trust the reviews from
anonymous strangers out there what can
we do in its stead and companies have
offered us a wonderful solution
they say the social graph will save us
and by this they mean that instead of
relying upon the reviews and comments of
strangers would you prefer to rely upon
the recommendations of your friends and
this sounds like a great idea at first
but I think it too is kind is dangerous
and I think this is exemplified by this
sponsored story if you don't know and I
share a lot of the examples in the book
there's this really interesting culture
on Amazon where there's farcical
products or real products where people
go crazy in the reviews writing funny
reviews George Takei mr. Sulu
he's quite he's a top Amazon reviewer
because he writes a lot of these
farcical reviews so for instance we have
a 55-gallon drum of sex lube George
Takei wrote a review of it in which he
said it was great and he sprays it when
revelers in the gay parade a gay pride
parade in San Francisco and this kid
Nick Burgas thought this was funny too
and he was an Amazon he said y'all share
this on Facebook for my friends to laugh
at and he said he 50 fine 55-gallon drum
of Lube on Amazon for Valentine's Day
and for everyday and for the rest of
your life little did he know that his
friends would start seeing his a face
appear in these ads on Facebook for this
product on Amazon and this happened to a
lot of people on Amazon
there was a class suit action against
Amazon in which they paid out millions
of dollars to various people and they
and eventually they stopped this
particular program but they continued to
do this sort of other thing and Google
Plus does this sort of thing and Twitter
Twitter might be moving to this sort of
thing and so that's why I spoke about
when I talked about this graph we're all
looking for a place where we can be true
to ourselves we can be authentic we can
express ourselves without fear of being
scammed and spammed and hit with the
sludge but eventually were pushed to
move and in fact even if we lived in a
world in which no one would ever hate on
you troll you scam you as they say
Craigslist folks do the platform's
themselves I think will chase away their
users resinar himself said a lot of the
problems that the social networks are
facing or because they just care about
having the most people they can have
Clay Shirky has this rule of something
like a comment system can be big cheap
or good pick two out of three you can't
have all of these things but they do
want all of these things and the way
that they try to get this is they have
lots of people online and then they sell
access to you as a user of their
platform so Yelp has come under a great
deal of attack for this though they have
so far won in the courts
so for example there were a number of
reports of how you're a merchant you're
sitting in your restaurant you get a
call from Yelp and they say would you
like to advertise with Yelp you say no
thank you
and they say well if you advertise with
Yelp we'd make sure a good review was
prominently displayed on your page and
when people were on your competitors
pages they'd see that ad for your place
and when people search for that kind of
restaurant they would find you and you
still say no thank you I'm doing very
well next day you have a horrible review
on your Yelp page written by a Yelp
employee
people said this is extortion this is
blackmail and went to the courts the
court said and I can dig into this more
if people want but they said no it's not
extortion so this leads me to conclude
that the social graph is actually not
going to save us but make shills of us
all that's what I'm worried about and so
here we have another geek in Polk
comic-con monetize your social graph hi
this is my friend Steve how much five
bucks in fact there was a Burger King at
app did anyone ever used that Burger
King Facebook app you would get if you
unfriended ten of your friends on
Facebook you get a free Burger King
burger and they got a lot of press out
of it they only had set so much money
for the campaign and when Facebook heard
about it they said you're abusing our
api's and they said well we don't care
too much because we're approaching our
budget for our campaign anyway but still
got them a lot of attention and I think
that's where we're potentially headed so
to wrap this out wrap this up I want to
focus back on that question of these WTF
moments right just so many questions
when you venture to the bottom of the
web this is one of my favorite pictures
does anyone know the story of this
picture of this monkey it's so
interesting I'm gonna digress for a
moment cuz it's such a fascinating
question this was a monkey that took a
picture of itself the guy left his
camera out in the jungle and a monkey
came along smile and took a picture of
itself lots of people started spreading
the picture online
Wikipedia hosted it and the photographer
said you're violating my copyright
that's my picture Wikipedia said no
monkeys don't have copyright in their
pictures and they actually prevailed so
you can find this picture on Wikipedia
okay so some of the things that perplex
me that prompt these WTF notice at the
bottom of the web why the heck do people
post first in the comments like there's
lots of weird things TL DR first WTF bye
like why here's an ad that went viral a
couple of years ago it's for a carbon
monoxide detector and a woman was on
this Canadian House Square site and she
bought it and she left a review and she
said this thing saved my son's life
four out of five stars and people are
like what the heck
right and so again I think there's
really interesting reasons as to why
this sort of happens in particular it
has to do with shared expectations and
commonalities of what we expect from
rating systems and do we overload rating
systems stupefying systems in this comic
there's someone is saying oh I read
something really horrible happen like
there was an earthquake or hurricane and
the other person said yeah it's awful I
liked it immediately so very often we're
overloading comments and rating systems
with just too much information I often
see lots of people and Amazon reviews
complaining about the fact that they
ordered the product but they mistakenly
ordered the wrong product I sent it back
I got the refund two out of five stars
and it's like well it's your fault that
you ordered the wrong product they did
everything they could possibly do why
are you giving the the product two out
of five stars or a lot of people are
very pissed off when they get a Kindle
version on their book that is misformed
because Kindles translation system
wasn't very good for a while and they
give the book 1 out of 5 stars it's like
no the book is really good it's just
Amazon messed up the Kindle the other my
other favorite example of that is pain
systems you go the doctor and they say
where is your pain 1 out of 10 like I
don't know does five mean in the middle
or does it mean like failing like I
would do to my student you got a 50% who
knows oops
I think so much of what we see online is
people making interesting but silly
mistakes so here we have the actor who
plays Dwight won the office he told his
assistant Joanne tell Del Taco
I will accept $12,000 to plug their
shitty food thanks oops right you forgot
to put the D in front of the twit tweet
we also have biases there's a very
famous blog that says I love
science and she had lots of followers
though apparently a lot of people did
not know that it was a woman that ran
the blog when she created a Twitter
presence she did have her picture
profile and dozens of people are like oh
my god it's a babe and so I think
because of the shortness of tweets and
the a-singin a synchronicity and a lot
of
their attributes we see this sort of
behavior and we also have excuses I keep
a running list of people that says I was
hacked because there's dozens of cases
of people saying they were hacked
we had the famous case of Anthony Weiner
who forgot to send forgot the prepended
e on his tweet when he took a crash shot
and sent it to a woman across the
country and where people were like well
what's going on he said originally he
said had nothing to do with him his
account was hacked people pressed him on
it he said well maybe it's a picture of
me but it was taken out of context I
don't know what appropriate context his
crotch shot would have been in everybody
said people get hacked all the time it
happens and so like what is going on and
I think if we go back to those original
attributes of comment that I outlined at
the start I think it explains a lot of
these phenomena so comma is reactive and
so I think that leads a lot of people to
post knee-jerk sort of responses they're
short so they lend themselves the
confusion and they're asynchronous and
so often you'll see more confusion and
pylons so I think for instance the fact
that Justine Sacco was a pretty famous
case where she tweeted something awful
before she got on a plane going to
Africa it says something like going to
Africa hope I don't get AIDS
oh wait I'm white I totally read that as
she's ironically pointing out the
privilege of herself other people
thought that was horrible and racist
this storm started brewing on Twitter
and the fact that she was on her plane
and disconnected and that the storm was
kind of rising and people started
calling for her to get fired Twitter
just blew up on this issue and and one
of the hashtags was has she landed yet
just thousands and thousands of tweets
and people like someone has to get the
airport and take her picture so you can
see her face when she turns on her phone
and somebody what something went to the
airport because of the asynchronous
nature of the communication she was out
of touch and when she landed she just
saw hundreds of messages saying you
horrible off a woman and from her
friends saying oh my god what happened
from our employer saying you're fired
but most importantly I think a lot of
this stuff that happens is because it's
hypo textual and by that I mean
actually comment in the web is naturally
hypertextual it's more than just text it
has links right you can connect from one
thing to another thing and that's the
wonderful thing about the web but I
think it's hypo textual in that it is
sometimes under textual so email
responses there's a reply header tweets
often are in context of another tweet
that you can find out though often it's
difficult but the wonderful contextual
'ti of all these comments and the fact
that they circulate so promiscuously
often means that those links are broken
and we have all kinds of
misunderstandings another case was a the
NRA posted something after the morning
of one of the many shootings
unfortunately we have had in the United
States and they said good morning
shooters how is everyone when people
were just like how could you say that
and the NRA had to say the person who
managed their social media account
wasn't aware of the shooting that
happened last night and I think that's
an example of so the hypo textual
framing of so much comment that's out
there so we're avant we've arrived at
the end of our expedition right our
journey to the bottom of the web and
what have we possibly learned so how can
we avoid the awfulness of the web I
don't think these are easy questions all
of them require a bit of work but I
think we're the most useful ways of
understanding comment platforms is by
way of the metaphor of a garden Tony he
see Coates who was here a couple of
years ago and talked about commenting
systems he likened a comment system as a
garden you just can't take an abandoned
law out in the corner and call it a free
speech libertarian paradise and expect
wonderful things you to have to happen
you have to spend resources and people
and time and attention
maybe codes of conduct and Institute
various norms such that you have a good
comment platform and good comments
emerge in your comment garden what
examples should and should not be
followed I don't think we should set up
spaces where people are intentionally
snarky or at least when we do that we
wouldn't support we shouldn't be
surprised when horrible things happen I
don't talk about feedback
today but I think a really nice example
of a comment culture out there is what's
called beta readers and the fanfiction
community they give feedback and comment
on one another's work and better reading
just like software development a beta is
something that's feature complete but
you put it out there because it probably
has bugs a beta reader is someone who
reads something that is you know written
but it's it's rough it's green and they
give you feedback and they have actually
a really strong culture and dozens of
really useful guides about how to give
feedback to one another and what dangers
are revealed beneath the silt when you
start pining panning the salt I think
there's a lot of manipulation out there
and so by reading the comments at the
bottom of the web I've come to the
conclusion that comment is only as
common terrible as we let it be so thank
you for your attention and I look
forward to your comments I feel very
good about it and good about myself
first in passing I just want to know I I
do think some of these problems can be
solved by more sensitive technology it's
fairly clear that if Facebook is able to
do facial recognition identification
Twitter should be able to sense that
this is a dick pic and warn you that you
should probably have a direct message in
front of it rather than sending it off I
mean this seems like something that we
can simply solve with technology more
seriously I'm curious you seem to be
talking about situations of comments in
perhaps the the the the least likely to
have some constructive conversation from
them so at the best reviews of books
yelp reviews that the worst comments
that quickly descend into trolling and
such there are other people looking at
comments with enormous aspiration
associated with them so for instance
we've seen in the news industry
newspapers trying to figure out is there
a possible way that their comments can
sort of serve as a forum for
deliberation and debate of the issues
that are sort of being brought
within them and thus far this seems to
be extremely difficult to pull off
is this a false hope it is is this a
space in which it's possible for
something like the choral project which
is now investing millions of dollars in
trying to figure out could you solve
newspaper comment saying having taken
this this deep spelunking expedition to
the bottom of the web is that a hopeless
task or do they have the possibility of
turning newspaper comments online into a
worthwhile space
okay so I'll talk about newspapers and
also talk about better systems so I'm
gonna begin with the better system is
because Facebook I had read that when
they started their system of trying to
report abuses for instance pornography
one of the things they found is once
they added that button that says you can
object to the thing that person posted
because it's obscene or something like
that they started getting deluged with
people reporting things and they'd go
and look and it was a Christmas picture
it was not obscene and the reason they
were getting all these photos reported
as being obscene when they weren't was
because people didn't like themselves in
the photo and they didn't have any other
mechanism to say I don't like myself in
this picture other than to say this is
obscene take it down and so they had to
get smarter about the system and maybe
you need to say well we need to create a
system whereby someone could say I don't
like myself in this picture but this
Facebook want to be in the middle of
that and so they architected such that
the message would go from the person who
was in the picture to the person who
posted the picture and they would play
with the you know the a/b test the ways
that the communication could be
facilitated to make sure something
nicely happens and it was a learning
experience and I think they have made
progress but the speaks to the fact that
it is a learning progress and if there's
any sort of incentive in such a system
for someone to sort of get around it or
abuse it it will happen so it's a Judith
Donna has a really nice book about user
interface design and she has a number of
neat proposals she's worked with in her
work here MIT about how we could design
better systems and I think we should
continue experimenting and playing with
it but I don't think there's necessarily
an easy solution once you scale above
the 150 or whatever the magic number is
for the
online context in the news context again
people have been experimenting there's
lots of different systems out there the
most popular system seems to be right
now that you have a different off to the
side commenting place where you allow
people to talk and you take the best
comments and maybe you promote them to
the front page under the newspaper
article that's nice in that it gives you
some reflection on that particular
posting but it's not necessarily a
robust conversation again I think we
have to apply what we've learned in
terms of one of my favorite examples as
metafilter
I think they're a really good comment
culture and they do a couple of things
they started out trying to construct a
good comment culture they had human
moderators and they charged the $5 fee
up front and it's not where they make
most of their money in fact they make
most of their money from Google Adsense
but just that $5 fee did a couple of
things one it prevented people from
doing drive-by comments and because they
have to register and pay the money and
maybe it also caused the cognitive
dissonance which is I've paid five
dollars to belong to this community
maybe I shouldn't be a jerk I want to
stay and hang around so I think there's
a lot of room for technological and
psychological experimentation to create
these spaces but it's not an easy job
and I haven't seen anything yet that
makes me think oh this is completely
solved and for instance one of the
things Tunde he seacoast has said he
said it's in McComb it's cool to create
in the community to see a post like when
New York Times it says 5,000 comments
posted take part in the conversation it
just isn't going to happen at that scale
and so I think if we want these sort of
things to happen and one of the reasons
I think reddit is successful is that it
allows you to have very specific
conversations and very specific
subreddits so it means that you have the
same platform and technologies in larger
cultural norms but you can actually find
a community that's very specific and
that has a decent scale to it and that's
just this you know this the social
psychology of groups so just before we
go onto other questions which we will
and a half a second I just want to
mention the judith donna book it's
called the social machine it is another
fine publication of the MIT
and yeah yeah it's a great question and
it's a very fuzzy sort of boundary and I
don't make the distinction though as to
say these people are clearly good and
these people are clearly bad rather I
make the distinction to say that most of
the research up to very recently assumed
that these were good people acting badly
under these computer mediated
circumstances but I think we should now
start tending to the fact that there are
also people maybe there are a fraction
of a percent who really are very
dangerous people very disordered people
and they can have a disproportionate
effect on what happens and so I would
never want to say well this person is
good and this person is bad Lindy West
is a comedian I think and a couple of
weeks ago she posted and gave a couple
of great talks about how she met one of
her fiercest trolls and she had this
amazing conversation it was also in this
American Life a podcast I really
recommend listening to it and this guy
just you know hurt her her father
recently passed away this guy created a
Twitter account in her father's name and
just would tweet these awful things that
she'd see and her father's name in his
phone her father's face and it really
affected her Twitter bio was a father of
two great kids and one idiot an
invention right and so you say well is
that guy good or is that guy bad and I'm
trying to set up that distinction per se
because when she spoke to him he said
I'm really sorry that's probably one of
the most awful things I've ever done I
was in a bad space she's a heavy woman
and she's and he said I was resentful of
the fact that you seemed happy and
successful and accepting of your body
and I just tore spilled it all out on
you and so again I'm not a psychologist
and I can't say exactly which one of
those categories he would be in it
sounds like he's a good person acting
badly but I make that other distinction
just to say that there are people who
are very scary and damaging and they can
have a huge effect
so most to quote Whitney Phillips who
also has a new book out from MIT press
about trolls specifically I quote her in
my book saying that among the troll
community she studies it was a
sausagefest to use her words and so it
is predominantly men though not always I
was quite surprised to learn that in the
UK they were talking about having a
woman author beyond the five pound note
and to remove Darwin and the people
behind that campaign received a whole
lot of vitriol and actually one of those
trollers who were saying awful horrible
things was a woman so it's not unusual
but very often it is men attacking women
and it's actually become enshrined as a
of culture like the type of hate speech
you see is very very formulaic so would
you like me to say anything more
specific than it is mostly guys though
not completely
[Music]
so Susan heron did some great work on
trolling in the 1990s I'm not sure if
you're familiar with her work and this
was even before the contemporary really
nasty hateful kind of stuff and she was
wondering why is it that men flame and
women thank those were the words that
she used and she thought that maybe men
and women have different notions of
politeness and when she would ask them
do you think is important to be a polite
online both men and women equally said
yes but what she found is something she
called like a free libertarian sort of
philosophical axis which is that the
women she spoke to seemed more concerned
about maintaining the face of the people
they were talking about and the men had
this various libertarian free speech
can't let anyone censor you you have to
like fight back and slam and dominate
the other sort of people so she found a
personality difference and I think
that's actually been enshrined in the
internet culture at large and I think
we're now starting to step back from
that to say look if you create a forum
where you allow anything to go with this
idea of libertarian free speech rules
awful things are going to manifest
unfortunately
yeah I've had that question a couple of
times I think it's a great question but
I haven't I would i would like to i it's
a it's an open question what's longer
much more thoughtful and it seems to be
much more genuine conversation going on
and so that like it's an example of
where someone takes money so there i
guess it very differently but it I'm
just wondering what other yeah well I
think requiring some sort of hurdle to
get in be it pay or something else I
think having a particularly dersh upend
culture started at the start where you
say these are the sort of things we want
to encourage and these are the sort of
things we want to discourage so when I
studied Wikipedia I thought the
Wikipedia founders Jimmy Wales in
particular did that well in that
community I had a couple of norms which
became policy that said this is the sort
of space that we want to create and it's
not perfect but I think that was
important and then there's the
technology do you make it easy to
moderate and manage the community
there's always room for improving upon
that and then there's also social
mechanisms like moderation meta
moderation with my cavi with that as
those things can always be gained and
abused so there's like a whole pan out
panoply whatever that word would be and
Penelope panoply Thank You of techniques
you have to do and it's not it's not
easy I teach a course on online
communities and we dig into all this
stuff throughout the whole this semester
because there's no you stick it out
there and you're ready to go if you do
that bad things are probably gonna
happen so
right I don't know if you've ever taught
students who then go when they graduate
and are on LinkedIn but I get many many
messages every day from all these
students and their friends saying
LinkedIn connect connect connect so I
haven't studied LinkedIn specifically I
was interested there's a chapter in
there where I talk about what I call
quantification and I think a big part of
this comment world is the fact that now
everything is quantified and rated right
so everyone gets stars and Beyond
LinkedIn there have actually been lots
of websites that will for instance take
your Klout rating and Klout as a measure
of your social influence do you have a
Wikipedia bio how many Twitter followers
do you have how many times you're
retweeted and they take this all the
social intelligence and give you a
number and there are sites out there
that allow you to rate your colleagues
and your peers and just as push towards
quantification in fact at one point
there were sites that would set up
dating among successful people and you
know they'd had be certain they had to
earn certain income and could only enter
the dating pool if they're Klout number
was a sufficient number so I am
concerned about the quantification of
everything that happens online and the
rating and ranking of everything online
but I haven't looked at LinkedIn that
much though I agree that they're very
promiscuous with sending you
opportunities to connect
[Music]
yeah
so there are both people who are
identifiable and act horrible and there
are people who are unidentifiable or
anonymous and don't act horrible
so for Plato then one would have to say
well there's a particular threshold so
maybe it's 20% of the people that would
act horrible and given the power of
invisibility and I'm actually always
very interested in threshold models like
people have studied when will a group of
people who are protesting turned into a
mob and these very narrow margins where
you could say you always have 20% of the
people will always cooperate or be
peaceful 22% of the people are gonna try
to cause trouble and the other 60% will
kind of go with what they see happening
around them and so what I suspect is in
any particular community you have that
sort of threshold model and if you
happen to have one of those people who
must always act poorly or antisocial II
and other people start taking their cue
you can have a community go very bad
very quickly we're a very similar
community that just has very small
difference on the margins could actually
be much more robust in pro-social so I
think the question of why does some
communities turn rotten so horribly even
though they seemed kind of similar at
the start relates to these threshold
models of collective B
go here and then you you're next I see
you so you talk too about corporate I
know I've seen on tumblr for instance
like sometimes tumblr users will get
anonymous comments I'm like well I'm
also a black woman and I disagree with
you on occasion those anonymous
commentaries will forget to click the
send this anonymously and it's like a
white dude saying so do you have the
information or know of any research on
that sort of like so not from a
corporate or military interest I I don't
have any quantifiable numbers I do know
that has happened and I talk a lot about
the social justice wars in the various
communities I study and that is fairly
common and people are embarrassed when
their real identities are released but I
don't have any figures on the particular
numbers one of the things I do talk
about by way of historical analogy is
Galileo and he's often thought to have
been persecuted by the church for
believing in a sun-centered universe but
in fact he had had good relations with
the Pope
God got along very well with the church
and the Pope actually said well I really
want to hear about this book you write
where you give both the heliocentric and
the geocentric model of the universe a
fair shake and what he did is he created
a sock puppet where he create he created
a geocentric simpleton actually named
simpleton and have had him mouthed the
literal words of the Pope and that's
what pissed the Pope off which then
called the hammer to fall down in
Galileo so people within sockpuppet in
for a very long time including for
strategic purposes where you don't
necessarily sockpuppet just to say I
agree with Joseph but maybe you say
Joseph is an idiot and among the
paranoid people online that's called a
false flag operation where you make
something appear that that's not really
happened that then you can have other
people pile on an attack
Galileo example there is some work
that's been done looking at Qatari
comment farms that have been responding
to human rights complaints in Bahrain
so Bahrain had a particularly bloody
crackdown on their corner of the Arab
Spring and for two or three years there
if you have the temerity to say someone
needs to hold Bahrain a US ally
responsible for human rights abuses you
would get just these torrents of I'm a
young female medical student in Bahrain
what do you know about my country you
know you should shut up and talk about
the problems in your own nation which is
a very effective way of actually getting
someone to back off human rights
critique except for the fact that it's a
common farm you know three countries
over you know trying to figure out
essentially how to manufacture a way to
silence dissent within it so there's a
little bit of work done on that and ways
in which Twitter comment farms
particularly around Russia right now are
being used as a way of some countering
design yeah and Russia they can be quite
sophisticated they can say we want one
of your personas to make a anti-putin
argument but we want the six other
personas to make the argument against
similarly in the book I show an example
where most of the things you find on
Craigslist are quite crude will be will
write reviews for you but one of the
specifications I need people to write
reviews for me and they were very
specific they're like you have to use
decent language you have to post your
posts in a over a long time spread out
like don't send all your reviews at the
same time there has to be a mix between
three and five stars and so some people
are quite sophisticated about creating
all this fakery out there and you just
can't assume that the fake reviews are
the zero stars of the 5 stars people are
getting very sophisticated about it
correctly as and the second time is just
commentary in the newest caracals I
wondered how do you think the difference
are are they following the same sort of
dynamics theory applied to those two
categories in the same way different
people write comments both of different
motivations so I'm gonna write on
another just one other people don't see
well this guy is great he write I think
you're right people have different
motives and I think there are different
effects in the book actually each one of
the chapters is divided up into how
comments can inform how comments can
help us how comments can alienate us
some of the things I didn't talk about
today is how comments can shape us so I
talk more about am i ugly videos and
other aspects of our interactions with
online media and comments so and how
comments befuddle us so yeah I think
it's a good question people have
different motives and they have
different effects and it's worth
considering each one of those hey
cultivate a good community and as the
social aspect of them the individual
responsibility of approaching things is
a beta reader
however those things are really hard and
they take a really long time and there's
an awful lot of assumption of people
taking personal accountability which
simply is not going to happen at least
for a long time and so I wonder if
you've also come across any if you have
logged anywhere communities that things
have gone well like I hear a lot the
League of Legends are the online play
and how they've dealt with the tribunal
and on this other stuff in order to have
people who have had a bad day or are
notoriously bad people how they deal
with that by putting in place a justice
system mmm have you blogged other
example
systems which help people get to those
both the society based the social base
of the individual accountability so
you're you're right I am making a
difference difficult sort of argument
once I was talking about this book to
someone they're like well what's the
easytek solution and I refer to Donna
look and I said there's a lot of really
good books ideas in there but I'm a
teacher because and I have students in
my classes on online communities and
communication of digital age because I
actually think education is an important
part of what we need to do and there's
no easy fix
similarly when I talked about Wikipedia
I was like there's no wiki dust that you
can spread and automatically your
corporate communications that are
amazing and you have all this amazing
collaboration I think League of Legends
is another really nice example we spend
a day on my online communities class
talking about that particular system and
for those people that don't know they
have a very mechanized system very
random where you play people you don't
necessarily know and if you act poorly
people will sort of tag you and say that
person's
acted poorly you get enough of those
there's some sort of secret threshold
and then you go into the tribunal system
where your peers are recruited and
typically these people don't know one
another and they make a decision and
they can ban you or put a sanction upon
you so I so when I talk about systems
that I think work well I actually talk
about League of Legends and I talk about
meta filter but very often I talk about
small scale communities and Reddit as
another big example because it allows
them to go small-scale but most of the
stuff that works out there I think
managed because it works at the small
scale so the League of Legends again
they have the small scale hack they say
we're gonna take 16 of your peers show
them the evidence and make a decision
[Music]
you must read it read it seems like I
like credit I like the little piece of
better I play around in but my
impression is that rhetoric is a
reservoir for some of the worst stuff on
the web as well say think about that
yeah so there's awful stuff on Reddit no
doubt there was lots of news when
someone by the name of violent acres who
was called Linda worse troubles on the
web about the various sub reddits he
created about upskirt videos and bound
louse videos and all this other sort of
creepy stuff right exactly right so it
is this really big amazing space I can
find lots of nice little communities in
which to exist in but if you create
these platforms your cars finally gonna
have bad spaces too I think and then the
community and the owners of Reddit have
to say this is stuff that we are no
longer want to see here and again I
think reddit started with this anarchist
stick free speech kind of ethos and that
was their concern at the start but I
think they got a not enough heat that
they said we're actually gonna crack
down on this with respect to gamergate a
lot of the harassment and organization
was happening at 4chan and the guy
behind 4chan was starting to get a lot
of heat on this any crack down on it and
they all went to eight Chan and so again
there's no easy solution and we can kind
of chase the haters and the misogynists
around the web but hopefully we can
chase them to places that people aren't
going to randomly sort of stumble with
upon that's my opinion
fortunately since they double every time
we can just preemptively block 32
chances actually do we have a final
question for Joseph I guess I'm thinking
there's also comments at the top of the
web and on the side for annotations and
and so I'm thinking about what the scope
of that is whether for instance a tweet
about an article is a comment about so
at the start I noted how I think comment
is reactive so it's in response to
something that's short it's asynchronous
and the reason I talked about the bottom
of the web is because I think that
speaks to the essence it's the things in
the margins it's the things in the
bottoms it's the stuff we don't
typically pay attention to and are
counseled to avoid that's what I wanted
to look at so um I want to thank Joseph
for being with us if we'd have a round
of applause for professor
[Applause]